now let's bring in one of the best in
the business the one we've been leaning
on for throughout this whole pandemic
dr. deborah birx Whitehouse coronavirus
response coordinator who doesn't seem to
need any rest because I watched you last
night outdoors and I'm watching you on
Sunday on every Sunday show and you're
back with us on Tuesday morning I think
I'm gonna put you in for a raise I'll
supply the paperwork a little bit later
dr. Burks but let's talk about what's
happening yesterday you kind of
surprised me with the testing are
getting Walmart and CVS and others
involved to ramp it up because in the
back of my mind is what you said on
Sunday there without any major
innovations we're not going to get
testing where we want it to be in the
not-too-distant future did you not
anticipate the private sector getting
involved in those announcements
yesterday no the private sector has been
involved it was the magnitude of
involvement I mean I think we've really
understood that you've got to bring the
test to the community you whether it's
drive through whether it's walk through
the community has to feel like tests are
available to them so just having it at
hospitals or clinics was not going to be
enough and so that part of this is
critically important to expand community
testing yeah dr. Brooks I you know we've
been talking a lot about statistics and
you have as well I was reading in the
New York Post Scott Atlas from the
Hoover Institute wrote an op-ed about
looking at the numbers and of the of the
people who are designated kovat
absolutely kovat deaths investigated in
new york 99.2% had underlying issues so
if 99 percent had underlying issues the
chances of a the average person a
healthy person getting it are small and
one of the things that I have heard from
my friends on zoom' and walking around
the neighborhood is maybe the government
overdid it
in closing everything down to make sure
that everybody was safe when in fact you
just had to protect a certain
demographic
no I think that's an interesting idea I
think what we have been looking at very
carefully is the explosive nature of
this virus and I think it's highly
contagious and so even in Phase one
we've asked every governor every public
health official to ensure whether you're
inside or outside to maintain social
distancing when you're in a public place
and to have a mask if you can't because
it's really really critical when you
look at the New York area where they
could get to two percent of the entire
population infected and hospitalized or
close to hospitalized or with serious
illness
we know there's mild symptoms but I
think what you really are getting to
does everyone know that they have an
underlying condition and do we know all
the underlying conditions that are
critical and I think adding asthma was
critical but also hypertension even mild
hypertension you know a lot of Americans
have that and so I think the converse of
that is how many Americans actually have
early signs of early diabetes early
hypertension asthma a lot of Americans
do and so we had an obligation to
protect all of Americans while we
collected the data of how contagious
viruses how rapidly it spread and then
how to really treat it when people get
to the hospitals yeah we see some of
these images of the beaches like the
ones in California where people are not
social distancing few are wearing masks
you see the boardwalks with with tons of
people and I know some of these are
families and they've been together for a
long time and so they're okay but not
everyone is social distancing and you
your recommendations I think it was two
days ago you said we need to think about
social distancing through the summer
what are your guidelines to the American
people that are watching right now yeah
I'm glad you mentioned that because what
we've talked about and even in phase one
and phase two we've asked people with
pre-existing conditions and
comorbidities to continue to shelter or
shelter as much as they can and that's
part of social distancing and then
everybody who's in those households has
to be scrupulous in their hygiene in
their protection and their social
distancing while they're out and the
reason this has become more and more
important is we're beginning to
understand more and more that there may
be an in
relationship for how severe the diseases
and your age so younger people could
actually be infected and not know they
are infected and unintentionally passed
the virus on and so that's why we need
everyone to be responsible and everyone
to take care dr. Burks how do you view
these daily updates doctor vouchers been
quoted by someone saying they're
gruelling that lasts for an hour and a
half
you're obviously involved in a political
situation when you're up there it
doesn't take much to see those questions
do you ever wonder about the benefit of
having them at the link that they are
for you personally and for the public to
be informed you ever wonder if if there
were I we're actually benefiting from
them I think it's really important that
the American people know the federal
government is collecting data every day
and doing everything they can to respond
to this epidemic and then passing on
insights across the country each state
is seeing something different and has a
different best practice and our job is
to ensure that through the governor's
call and through the and through those
conferences press conferences that press
briefs that we actually are able to
communicate key new findings and new
insights that governor's have noticed
states have brought us and certainly
that we see in the data I just ask you
today by actually hearing what dr. Burks
would you like to change without those
briefings I'm sorry I couldn't hear you
would you like to change anything about
those briefings you know I think I'm a
PowerPoint kind of gal I'm very
data-driven I really like to use that
time to educate the American people so
you know if I've got a graph behind me
I'm extraordinarily happy I think the
American public the more knowledge the
American public has about this epidemic
where it is on a county-by-county wet
dialog is really critical and the more
communities know the more they can
protect themselves and so I'm always
happy when we can do graphics and talk
to the American people well I started to
say I enjoy seeing the briefings with
the leaders
the end of the day to figure out what
they've done it was good to see the CEOs
of the testing companies and the big
retailers yesterday talking about the
national strategy but dr. Burks going
back to what Ainsley had talked about
with you regarding social distancing and
particularly the idea of wearing a mask
we had a story about 20 minutes ago that
apparently JetBlue is going to require
people on the airplane the passengers to
wear some sort of a face covering and
I'm just wondering going forward how
much face covering are we going to see I
mean my daughter was supposed to get
married this Saturday but they put out
the wedding for three months and that's
right
Sally's watching somewhere she's gonna
get married in August now but going
forward you know will the will people at
the wedding be wearing face coverings
because they'll be dancing and things
like that going to sporting events will
people be in stadium seats with a face
covering what do you think going forward
America looks like well this is what we
know about this virus we know that
talking singing certainly sneezing and
coughing can pass the virus on to others
and because you can pass it when you're
asymptomatic people don't know that
they're infected and so if there's virus
in the community or you're gathering
people from different areas of a state
where there may be still residual virus
and no virus if everybody wears a face
mask then you're protecting the other
person because it's really having the
asymptomatic individuals wearing masks
but since you don't know if you're one
of those really everyone needs to in
those kind of social gathering
situations as long as there's virus
still in the community yeah dr. Burke
sure just to piggyback on what Brian was
saying you were you're very smart you're
up there every single day we know you're
not getting any sleep and we thank you
for what you're doing we're sorry that
sometimes politics does does play a role
in all of this because I know you just
want to get the facts out there and your
your medical points are more important
than the politics you care about every
single American and we appreciate what
you're doing I want to ask you about the
fall what are your predictions for the
fall I know New York is different than
certain parts of the country but are you
thinking that I know that as you said
weddings are gonna be different
we might be wearing masks at weddings in
the fall but do you think schools will
start back up and how do you think this
is going to change America going forward
you know it's a great question nor
normally northern hemisphere respiratory
disease is moving to the southern
hemisphere during the summer because
it's their fall it will be very
interesting to watch Australia New
Zealand southern Africa and Chile in
Argentina to see what happens with the
virus in the summertime and what's
happening to the virus here so really
those two pieces together will really
define how we do in the fall our job
right now and our job in the White House
to ensure that we are ready for anything
that happens in the fall whether it's
testing whether it's PPE whether it's
ventilators whether it's a complete
surveillance system that understands
that we have to track for asymptomatic
s' as well as symptomatic individuals
all of those pieces need to accelerate
and expand to be ready for the fall all
right dr. Burks thanks so much you will
we'll see you today at 5:00 we think if
there's a briefing